All species with the genus name, Homo, indicates a form of human. And our
closest human relatives are technically neanderthals or Homo neanderthalensis,
even though they recently went extinct several tens of thousands of years ago.
Homo erectus and Homo habilis, our more distant human relatives, but they went
extinct a long time ago. It turns out that our closest living relatives are in
fact chimpanzees. One of the main ways we know that humans are most closely
related to chimps is that a remarkable amount of our genetic information
between humans and chimps is the same. An amazing 98%. But those few genetic
differences are responsible for the important structural differences,
especially with regards to the brain, which is what makes us uniquely human.
This change over time is referred to as evolution. And it's achieved through a
well-established mechanism of mutation and natural selection. Let's learn a bit
more about how natural selection works.